I mean there is something to enjoy about
this goodbye hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to subnautica now
first off yes my hair is blue this is
the first game that I've recorded with
blue hair and that might be confusing
because you've seen quite a few videos
with pink hair and that's because I'm
pre recording a lot of videos because
I'm about to go back to Cincinnati to
visit my family and friends for
Christmas break or happy holiday break
or whatever you celebrate break it
really doesn't matter to me I'm just
going back so I can spend some time with
my family and that's gonna be really
cool but that being said I'm trying to
record over 40 videos before I go so
there's a lot of stuff that needs to be
done there's a lot of stuff that needs
to be seen and this one in particular is
a highly requested game that I'm gonna
be playing for you guys that I know
nothing about and usually I don't know a
lot when I go into games because for the
most part I'm bad at games and I'm not
doing too terribly good at any given
time but this one in particular as far
as I know is like a crafting survival
game that it takes place underwater and
if you know seriously I've never even
seen like gameplay this with you and
hold on I have to change something real
quick okay that's just gotten marginally
good enough so I know nothing about this
game and I kind of did that
intentionally like that's so cool I've
never seen any any gameplay of this I've
never seen anyone play this game and I
know that Jack has played it but I
haven't even asked him about the game
besides should I play it and he said yes
so that's as far as I know anything
about this oh I thought I was in a chair
for some reason anyway so this game is
also an early access which means will
okay not cool I knew it took place
underwater but I didn't know that it was
gonna start out like Bioshock with the
plane going down into the darkness I
mean it seems like the ship is normally
intact so did I even need to jettison I
mean maybe there's people surviving on
the board of that ship okay whatever I
don't know if I was supposed to do that
I hope I have a diving suit because look
at the weird fish I mean we are on an
alien world I didn't even know we'd be
in an alien world I thought we were just
on okay so the main objective of this
game is just to survive as far as I know
so I'm gonna be oh really oh oh that's
so cool what is that
that's an butthole oh that's a shadows
oh that's so cool
I can deform the environment I've loved
deforming the environment since I played
okay I was supposed to be watching for
that I didn't know I could deform the
environment or I love deforming the
environment since I played magic carpet
to on the PC long ago that in populace 3
by bullfrog entertainment a great gaming
company that fell out break limestone Oh
acid mushroom hell yeah it's gonna be a
party under this ocean so I hope I'm
doing good but apparently there's
limestone to be broken how do I break
limestone oh hi oh you're not good are
you oh I hate the ocean did I mention
that I hate the ocean hello I know the
PDA is there probably should be looked
at because it has instructions or
whatnot but I'm a little worried about
whoa hi buddy how are you how you doing
buddy hey you got a club like explodey
tail at least that's what the lights
usually mean for me can I pet you can I
eat you oh you don't seem to agree with
me whoa what is that oh my god there's
so many noises hi you've got a funky
face oh you're releasing it did you just
pee you just go number two I don't even
know if aliens okay that sounds bad
should I worry about Oh God this gives
me oh man don't grumble and me are you I
got it I got it I got it I'm in ok there
we go ok so I'm gonna go back in and I'm
gonna read my PDA because that's what I
probably should have done before I
started this game but god damn I hate
the ocean there's so many creepy crawly
things in there that you have no idea
what they're doing and this is in a
completely different world what could it
possibly mean titanium
alrighty then whoa I can't there we go
okay my mouse went a little awry I pump
air from the surface so I know that
there's some sort of like build II do
things like you can construct innate
them some things and do that in general
let me open my PDA whoo Oh filled my
entire inventory with acid mushrooms I
probably shouldn't have done that but
whatever 87 percent I do oh I have more
okay so I can fabricate a whole bunch of
titanium
well that's handy that cool it turns it
into a very blocky cube of titanium
symbols on it cool
[Music]
oh cool I mean I always did like these
crafting guides her games guides these
crafting type games because they did
have the lot of potential for cool
gameplay but often you'll find that the
cool gameplay is kind of replaced by
people trying to make money with
crafting and survival games which was
why there was a bunch of when people
fell out of it I mean there were some
fun ones but there were some really bad
ones I'm just assuming that I need to
turn it into an ingot to get it clear on
my inventory
okay blueprints I'll probably flip
through the blueprints in between
episodes so I don't waste too much of
your time am I supposed to do with these
okay whatever so there's there's logs no
life signed attacted there's radiation
leakage which is probably bad so
eventually I'm gonna need to build a
home which is really interesting but I
do have titanium but I probably should
get more stuff so I'm gonna go out and I
imagine that this life pot isn't gonna
last forever especially in this ocean
probably gonna sink down into the deaths
hello fishies are there more weird
monsters for me to be eaten by I mean
another thing that I have to do is I
have to find a way to get more air on
these expeditions oh okay well I didn't
really need that I had plenty of salvage
oh this is so weird I know that sounds
so bad I just know for a fact that I'm
gonna get eaten by something big and
very scary very soon I mean if I start
venturing off into the deep I know the
death is the only thing that's gonna
await me okay but it is interesting that
I can deform the environment and do
whatever I want with it I mean this must
what it mean to be able to just be
totally free I mean a lot of people like
this game it's very highly reviewed so
that's pretty cool oh oh a seaweed or
whatever the alien equivalent of seaweed
is hello I am from Earth are you the
intelligent species of this planet I got
him human no narcosis I don't know what
that means but I got something
I can make it see I don't know if
there's a way to sprint or anything I'm
pretty sure I'm at one speed the entire
time almost there with the music I get
it I know are you gonna meet my sassy
computer wife for this adventure
that's a weird boxing in the ocean top I
guess I just keep gathering up materials
there's too many noises I mean seriously
the ocean is the scariest thing in
existence and this is an alien ocean
that means this Horrors beyond by
imagining I mean I don't even know it's
in our oceans
nobody knows what's in our oceans we
haven't seen everything yes I mean can
you imagine what horrible monstrosity
would be on an alien ocean planet maybe
there's no land anywhere here damn it I
don't have anything to eat
I got acid mushrooms I don't know but it
probably means bad news for me I think I
don't exactly know what I'm supposed to
be doing but oh now my courts okay so I
got silicon rubber but I don't know what
that do so I need to get some food but I
don't know how to get through I may die
I may die and I may play badly and
that's totally understandable I will I
am totally accepting if people are gonna
be critical of what I'm doing because
honestly I have no idea what I'm doing
and it seems like there's actually a
power meter and I probably shouldn't
just be spamming it with one I guess
but it's hey survival knife I like the
sounds of that can I stab something over
I can stab something ok so I got no Hoya
Buhl's I got very few tools maybe I
shouldn't have turned it all into ingots
probably shouldn't have done that
I should probably pay attention to stuff
that I'm doing it's getting night I
don't like the ocean at night survival
knife ha oh god oh god
I thought it was it's an air sac I'm not
putting my mouth on that there's no way
in hell I'm putting my mouth on that oh
god what do I do with you what do I do
what do we do with you oh god it's night
oh hey night oh god it's night okay
so ooh do I still oh god I do why Oh
Chris Lee thankfully odorless and spongy
did I mention spongy oh thank you cooked
air sac exactly what I've always wanted
oh oh I got an air sac in my face oh god
oh god oh god oh god I know I'm probably
supposed to go towards the ship at this
point buzzer
yeah you didn't come back here I'm here
I want to eat you I don't even know if
this like how do I even know who it was
it read table quarrel I can't do
anything with it I probably need another
tool there's a lot of noises but I mean
seriously how do I know that any of
these creatures are actually gonna give
me sustenance oh I'm scared of the ocean
the ocean is a big scary place don't
blame me okay so I didn't get anything
new damn it
okay last try that I don't know what
glass could do but it's probably just
best to get as many raw materials as
possible okay still nothing new
alright let's go back down oh god oh god
what is it oh god I thought I was just
on the surface oh oh no oh no what are
you Oh No okay okay I'm assuming it
there's got to be some way that I can
actually use this air sac cuz I mean air
sac would make sense but maybe I just
need a whole bunch of them I can string
them all together and then slap them
just for fun you know I really do
anything I don't know what that means
I hate the ocean oh god I hate the ocean
oh oh is that a thing oh that's the
thing is a nice huh lights in the
darkness that's at that legitimately
scared me I thought it was the thing
sorry everybody serious mark Blair here
to do some serious siren singing for
this science adventure I mean there is
something to enjoy about this but look
me
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh I know I
know
Oh Oh God oh god oh god oh god oh god
give me give me give me give me oh God
Oh what was that I don't know what this
game is doing oh man that's good the
crap out of me I hate the ocean guys I
hate the ocean legitimately hate it let
me know don't mind it like it's good
that it's there in existence but god I
hate it oh it's so scary all the time
there is no point at which the ocean is
not scary you would never catch me dead
in the ocean okay that was that all of
them are do I have somewhere I have some
more okay okay
so those offer food and some water which
is awfully nice that sounds bad what do
I do about that do I have to get away
from it Oh was I supposed to go to it
sooner so I could get things before they
blow oh that's probably exactly what I'm
supposed to do I'm such an ass oh god
what is with the noises there are things
that are trying to get in my pod where
to go oh there it is all right I guess I
could I guess I should try
I still don't know what attacked me
something attacked me it was not cool
bro not cool at all okay so this is
gonna be my Trek because it seems like
that thing's gonna blow and it's either
gonna blow me with me in it and never
going in the comments is like oh you
fool don't go towards it yeah you all
have very epic and nice voices and
you're very handsome in whatever or
beautiful depending on what you want to
be but frankly I have to explore the
unknown that's part of what being a
markiplier is all about and I'm not
gonna be oh god it's so scary oh so
scary oh it's so scary in this ocean
it's beautiful let's go oh god it's
getting deeper see the worst thing about
is that you can't see the bottom even if
you go a little bit in the ocean you
don't know what's underneath you oh god
my life raft is so far away well son so
scary I don't know what's up with the
graphical bugs but I played this on
recommended graphical difficulty because
it said that the higher level is
experimental but I might try that a bit
later if it's a little better oh it's so
scary oh that's so scary even that is
scary just like seeing something in the
fog of the ocean what is that can I even
get closer to this thing is this
actually something maybe this is
actually nothing and I'm just being an
idiot probably hey I am markiplier I'm
known for being dumb I'm leaving my pod
everyone in the comments is screaming
had me too no don't do that dog dog dog
dog well too bad I'm already stupid
party
okay alrighty then
this is a bad idea this is a bad idea
Oh God radiation detected oh it's a
stupid idea why did I go oh god I'm
dying a slowly this is so stupid why did
I go here why did I go here why did you
guys let me go here you guys should have
told me that I shouldn't have gone there
why oh hello hello noises in the deep
hello scary scary noises in the deep
ocean so much no man I know the clicky
thing probably isn't an enemy because he
didn't attack me before unless at night
he turns into a horrible monstrosity
that wants to eat my soul it's cool it's
chill I'm chill whoa hello can I stab
you I've got a knife I just want to stab
you a little bit for research show
severe instability in the primary drive
core the central Dark Matter reactor
will reach a supercritical state
t-minus oh oh no I do that oh oh can I
see it at least probably gonna kill me
nice now is the radiation hello-o no
radiation still here huh oh that's bad
well that's really bad isn't it okay so
there's no going home for me huh and
none of the other colonists survived
well that was a bit of a fruitless task
but here I am slightly better for it I
guess I'm just gonna go into my pot I'm
just gonna go into my pod now and then
cry because I'm all alone and everyone
that I knew and loved is now dead self
charging power cells oh boy
but I do bet that now it's probably
going to stop bleeding radiation cuz
that's how radiation works right they're
just you know state decides to stop
after a while alright so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna fabricate up some stuff
and I'm gonna survive this because
nothing's gonna stop the markiplier from
being the ultimate survivor no matter
the cost
okay so so I've got a lot of stuff that
means I can fabricate the right tools if
you all believe in me hard enough that
I'm gonna survive this I know for a fact
that I will survive yay oh boy that's
good that's good right oh that means I
can dive deeper oh I can make cool okay
cool cool okay cool alright so I just
need to go get more basic materials and
then get started on my own personal
venture okay cool so I know what I need
to do so I'm not doing too terribly for
someone that's just getting started in
the game and not knowing what I'm
supposed to do heck I probably made a
lot of mistakes but I'm not dead yet oh
hey there we go thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want to give me
tips and tricks let me know down in the
comments below
and thank you again everybody for
watching
being here and thank you for enjoying my
blue hair I'll probably be in Cincinnati
hanging out with my friends but I'll
still be doing a lot of Christmas
specials and Christmas themed videos in
general thanks again and as always
[Music]